find the missing value to make the table
represent a linear equation so let's see
this table right over here so when X is
equal to 1 Y is three-halves when X is 2
y is equal to 3 so let's see what
happens when X increased by 1 so when X
increased by 1
what did Y do well it looks like Y
increased by 3 and 1/2 is the same thing
as 1 and 1/2 so to go from 1 and 1/2 to
3 it increased by 1 and 1/2 or you could
say it increased by 3 halves you could
say that 3 is the same thing as 6 halves
6 halves minus 3 halves is another 3
halves all right now when we go from 2
to 3 we're increasing by 1 again in the
in X and what are we doing in Y so we're
going from 3 which is the same thing as
6 halves to 9 halves so once again we
are increasing by 3 halves so in order
for this to be a linear equation or a
linear relationship every time we
increase by 1 in the X direction we need
to increase by 3 halves if we increase
by 2 we need to increase by 2 times 3
halves so what are we doing over here on
this fourth term on the table well we're
increasing we're going from 3 to 8 so we
are increasing by 5 so we're if we're
increasing X by 5 then we need to
increase Y we increase Y by 5 times 3
halves or 15 over 2 that's the amount
that we have to increase we have to
increase Y by if we started at 9 halves
and we're going to increase by 15 halves
so it's going to be 9 halves plus 15
halves this is how much we increment by
remember we increment 3 halves every
time X moves 1 this time X moved 5 so
we're incrementing by 15 halves or you
could say we're incrementing by 3 halves
5 times but this is going to be equal to
9 plus 15 is 24 over 2 which is equal to
12 and so in the box we could write 12
and we are done